today i'm going to show you a
do-it-yourself parasite cleanse
concoction i have to say i hate
parasites you know why because they take
but they don't give back
like at least friendly bacteria they
provide vitamins immune protection but a
parasite is kind of like a little
criminal it takes something it doesn't
give anything back and that definitely
applies to these worms now the most
common parasite worm in western europe
and united states is the pinworm they're
about one centimeter long and when
you're exposed to them the eggs can
survive for a period of think three
weeks in your body and then they
actually hatch and then they can even
reproduce and so they're pretty nasty
and so i'm going to show you a really
good natural remedy that you can make on
your own i recently made mine not that i
have pinworms but i just want that
remedy on the shelf
now 20 of children
are going to get pin worms sometime in
their life
probably from like nail biting or finger
sucking and 30 of the people who get pin
worm have absolutely no symptoms but for
those that do get symptoms the number
one symptom is anal itching at night
okay number two grinding of the teeth
three insomnia four restlessness five
stomach pain and nauseousness
six bedwetting and number seven which is
not really a symptom it's just a a point
i was i was going to make 36 percent of
people that get utis end up having pin
worm which is actually quite interesting
because it just tells us their
environment
is very attractive for growing parasites
and so if you do have a history of utis
i have a very good video i'm going to
just put that in the section below so
here's the remedy black walnut halls now
where i live
it's you can walk down the street and
find these you can go in the park and
find these they're in your backyard
they're all over the place so the hall
is the kind of a green
shell around the walnut and it's very
very uh bitter
it's very very concentrated and it has
certain elements that are really good to
kill pinworms ringworms tapeworms it's
very anti-microbial
now you want to make sure that you use
gloves because it will stain your hands
for
weeks
so what you want to do is you want to
get these walnut holes and you want to
get several that are kind of soft but
they're not dark brown yet and then you
want to cut them in half take the nut
out okay you can dry that for a couple
weeks and actually eat eat the walnuts
but what you're interested in is this
hull this surrounding green part which
you're going to put in a jar okay a
quart wide mouth jar and you're going to
add a mixture of half
alcohol and half
water i do recommend vodka
but you can also use apple cider vinegar
it's just not as strong
but the way that we made ours is with
vodka
now inevitably you know every time i'm
at the store and buying something for
research purposes like vodka
inevitably someone's going to be in
there that has been watching my videos
so i'm here i am in the liquor store i'm
looking around making sure no one sees
me and then i go right up to the
lady at the checkout and she goes oh dr
berg i watch all your videos and i'm
like okay great it's not what it looks
like okay this is for experimental
purposes we're gonna we're making a
parasite cleanse and she's looking at me
like
you're making a parasite cleanse with
vodka yeah right
so no she didn't believe me but anyway
hopefully she's watching this video
right now so you're gonna take a
combination of alcohol and water
a one to one ratio and you're going to
basically pour it into this jar where
you have
several of these
black walnut hulls which are basically
green because the hole is green in the
actual nut it's black we're not using
the nut so basically we top it off so we
have all these holes that are being
bathed in this alcohol mixture
and the thing about the alcohol it's
going to
help extract
these phenols about 14 different
powerful phyto
nutrients that are very very potent
seriously potent antioxidants as well as
having antimicrobial properties so
you're going to leave it in this jar
which you're going to put a lid on for
about
four weeks in a warm place don't keep it
outside where it's cold because it's not
going to work as well and so you're just
going to keep it there and then at the
end of a month
you're going to strain the fluid out
you're going to put this mixture in
tincture bottles with a dropper then
what you do is you just take one drop or
full whatever liquid comes up in the
dropper okay and put that in a little
glass of water and just chug that down
once a day now if your children have pin
worms okay or tape worms or ring worms
you can just use
half of the dropper okay so that way
it'll be a bit more mild now there's a
couple other things you can do you can
use wormwood garlic and clove they also
work really good you can even buy this
in a supplement if you don't want to
make it but i'm really into making
natural remedies from nature that
don't really involve too much complexity
now regarding black walnut halls there's
some fascinating research that's being
done by pharmaceutical companies for
various remedies so apparently
they get a lot of ideas
for certain properties from nature
and then they extract them they
synthesize them and they patent them to
come up with remedies but why not just
use something that mother nature has
provided us
and so at a fraction of the cost you can
now make your
own parasite tincture oh by the way if
you haven't seen my other video on
parasites i put it up right here check
it out